people on beaches along Florida's East
Coast are finding massive clumps of
seaweed from a huge blob floating in
from the Atlantic Ocean now tractors are
cleaning up the unsightly end smelly
mess but there are concerns much more
could be on the way and what this might
mean for their environment and tourism
Manuel before kids it's in Miami Manuel
good morning
good morning to you it's about this time
once the sun has come up where you can
really see what has washed up onshore
overnight this seaweed is known as
sargasm and it is expected to keep
coming in waves over the next several
months
it's very undesirable Oscar Vasquez has
owned his Miami beach condo for more
than 25 years and says he's never seen
this much sargasm a seaweed this early
there are parts of the beach where it's
undesirable and difficult to get into
the water
specialized tractors have been raking up
the clumps of brown weeds that line
these beaches but by the time the sun
rises again
they're usually back
sargasm that is picked up is destined
for landfills but before it's piled just
offshore releasing a foul odor not to be
overly dramatic I feel that maybe I
bought in the wrong place really
yeah because this is not what I
bargained for the seaweed is naturally
occurring but this year scientists say
there's a bumper crop on an average
March since 2011 there's been this much
of it in What's called the Great sargasm
belt this year there was this much an
estimated 13 and a half million metric
tons which could reach beaches in the
Caribbean and Florida over the next few
months all the seaweed a FIFA abdulgani
studies sargasm at the University of
Miami when Wastewater is released into
the river systems and makes its way into
the ocean you have all that nutrients
that can be found in Wastewater and they
help fertilize the sarcasm
she's analyzing what productive human
uses it might have instead of putting it
into a landfill we wanted to compost it
a usable product can be made from it and
yes it can be composted but that's still
in the research stage until then
Miami-Dade County officials say beaches
will be cleaned daily eager to protect
tourism revenue and property values
maintain the beaches Miami-Dade County
mayor Daniela Levine Cava says they must
be careful to also protect Wildlife we
have to get a permit for removal from
the state and there are also federal
guidelines protecting the native species
we can't put out barriers because that
would be injurious to Wildlife so it's a
delicate balance trying to keep the
beaches free of the sargasm and also
trying to protect the the wildlife
that's there absolutely it's a balance
that I think we've done very well
maintaining
they are not allowed to scoop it out of
the water for example because fish
hatchlings and other creatures could be
living in it the county has set aside
3.9 million dollars this year for
sarcasm removal but it's asking the
state for an additional two million
dollars because of how much more is
still out there Nate
man welcome thank you